Speaker 1: All right. Dozens of you sent me the
video I'm about to play and this story. And I'm
going to present the story to you as best as I
understand it. There is a video that has gone
completely viral of a guy wearing an oxygen mask
that people said, David, this guy is an American
who faked his death. He's pretending to be Irish
with an obviously fake accent and covering his
face with an oxygen mask. This is a completely
insane situation. So before we play the video,
I'm going to do my best to explain to you
what this is all about. There's an independent
article called Fugitive accused of Faking his Own
Death, sobs as he insists, I'm an Irish orphan.
Okay. Nicolas Rossi, also known as Nicolas
Alla Verdean, appeared on U.S. TV claiming
mistaken identity. He is a suspected rapist. Said
to effect his own death while on the run from the
FBI and living in Scotland. And he appeared on
NBC's Dateline and he was confronted and told,
you know, people believe you are Nicholas Allah
verdean. And it all completely exploded. He's
35 years old. He now wears an oxygen mask in
public. Again, it's unclear whether it's for
a medical reason or to hide his face. He claims
to be Irish orphan Arthur Knight, a victim of
mistaken identity who has never stepped foot
in the United States of America. Last November,
Sheriff Norman McFayden Fadiman ruled that
Rossi was the man U.S. authorities were seeking,
but he says he's just a different person.
If you look at the wiki page about this.
It says Indeed, Nicholas Allah Verdes and known
as Nicholas Rossi and Arthur Knight is an American
sex offender who faked his own death in 2020.
So I'm going to play the video for you here.
I hope I now am getting the details right. This is
a guy who says I'm an Irish orphan, but in reality
is an American who faked his own death, I believe,
to avoid legal trouble. Okay, Chuck, this this,
this is. I've never seen anything like this.
Speaker 3: We were once a normal family,
but thanks to the media, our lives have been
interrupted. And we think privacy. And I would
like to go back to being a normal husband.
Speaker 1: Now, one of the weird things is
he, I guess, claims to be Irish, but
I don't think that's actually an Irish
accent. That sounds like sort of a British
accent, which is a strange detail for sure.
Speaker 3: But I can't because I can't read.
I can't walk. People say that's not. Let me
try to stand up. Let me try to stand up.
Speaker 1: So he tries to he, I guess,
tries to stand up. And again, it's unclear whether
the being unable to walk is part of the disguise
as well. I just don't know. He sort of, quote,
tries to stand up and the person who's with them.
I think I think it's a woman who's with
him kind of like reacts like, oh, no,
I've got to save this guy.
Speaker 3: Exactly. Exactly.
Speaker 4: What do you say to someone who believes
that that you are Nicolas Solidarity. And I am.
Speaker 3: However, Andrea, I cannot make
this and I do not know how to make this call.
Speaker 4: What do you say to people who say
these are crocodile tears? He's putting on
a show. This is all an act. Oh, you know.
Speaker 1: That's one. And the woman on the
left is treating him like he's a crying seven
year old boy. It's all completely bonkers. So
at some point, maybe we'll know more. But the best
assessment I have of this, I mean, this this this
is a story that it it went viral. If we weren't
living in such insane times as we find ourselves
living in right now, this would have gone even
more viral. Like without even a shadow of a
doubt. This is completely bonkers. And again, I
don't know if the I think he's in a wheelchair.
Oxygen mask, dark rimmed glasses. Claiming to
be Irish while speaking in a British accent.
I think that that's all part of the disguise.
But I have never seen anything like this. Not
a criminal genius. I think it's fair to
say, and I'm struggling to believe that
this is actually an Irish orphan. Insane
story. Let me know what you think about it.